hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the magnus invitational we
are continuing with our match uh magnus
carlton versus dingleroon and this is
game four of their match uh so two games
were one were won by ding and one
game was won by magnus so ding is in the
lead and the magnus needs to win this
one to get back into the match and force
armageddon
so without further ado let's see if we
get surprised
by yet another game and if you've seen
the thumbnail
i'm sure you know what i'm talking about
so magnus goes for e4 we have e5 binding
and here magnus brings out the big guns
he goes for the king's gambit with
f4 and it's always exciting moment at
least for me
when uh whenever anyone plays the king's
gambit and it's one of those gambits
that is best
refuted by accepting it so this is
exactly what ding does he goes for e
captures on f4
accepts the king's gambit and knight to
f3
now just continuing development we have
knight to f6
now immediately going after the e4 upon
and e5 by magnus
immediately advancing that pawn and now
knight to h5
ding knows his king's gambit theory the
the knight will be very useful here
uh guarding the f4 pawn so queen to e2
by magnus
and bishop to e7 now uh we have d4
the uh strengthening the center and the
now castles binding and the knight the
c3 by magnus
and here there is one game in the
database where d5 was played but here d6
biting
is a new move and already as of move
seven we have a completely new game
so it's it is kind of problematic for
magnus to develop the dark square bishop
since the knight on h5 guards this pawn
you can't
just recapture it so bishop to d2
and now bishop to g4 and this will be uh
with this will be a difficult uh task
to break up this structure how do you
get rid of this pawn how do you
move anything uh since the bishop is now
pinning the knight
but that's why uh why magnus decided to
play the uh
the king's gambit so we have queen side
castles uh and the knight
to d7 putting more pressure on the
center so queen to e1 unpinning
preparing bishop to e2 to counter black
slide square bishop
and c6 now we have bishop to e2 and then
now comes
rook to e8 and now magnus goes for g3
and it's a pretty common thing in the
king's gambit when the f4 pawn is
protected you want to give up the g3
pawn and even the h2 pawn to create some
attacking
chances on the king side which you will
see a lot when we continue our morphe
saga
so d captures an e5 uh grabs in the
center we have knight captures on e5 now
opens up an attack on the bishop we have
knight captures on e5 d captures on e5
and
now f3 so by doing this ding has created
a past pawn on f3
but magnus had to do something as there
was really no way for him to start
developing pieces
bishop to d3 and now queen to d4
a beautiful centralizing move by the
queen also guards f2
so this prepares f2 with an attack on
the queen and also this will open up an
attack against
the rook from the bishop on g4 so magnus
immediately goes queen e4
a force is a queen trade as now the
bishop is under attack
but also the the h7 pawn so being trades
we have queen captures
knight captures and now f2 uh saving his
spawn while also
attacking the rook here so rook d to f1
blocking the pass pawn and now bishop to
f3 biting and now
there is no way to save the rook you
either give it up or you
you give up the exchange that's pretty
much all you can do here
but carlson finds a way to make things
interesting he goes for g4
he tries to give up uh the bishop the
pawn here so
the rook might survive but ding goes for
the absolute strongest move he goes
bishop to h4
he defends the pawn here while giving up
the knight here
and there's not much white can do here
now you're losing the exchange that's
for sure but at least you can you can
win a piece while doing it so this is
what ding goes for we have g
captures on h5 and now not grabbing the
rook right away if you grab the rook
right away then broke captures and
after rook captures on e5 you just go
back rook to f1
and you keep you keep playing this
position
and you you will have a good good
defending chances
so instead of grabbing the rook right
away ding first goes for rook captures
an e5 which now creates a double attack
on the knight here so immediately
threatening to win back the piece
with knight to g3 by magnus getting it
out of the way and now just rook eight
to e8 putting a lot of pressure on this
e1 square
and there's no rush to capture the rook
this rook is not going anywhere
so here magnus played bishop to c3 he
created an attack here against the rook
but uh it doesn't work
uh as here dean just played uh well
there are a lot of moves that are good
here and here you can actually capture
or you can just move the move the rook
from harm's way but bishop g5 check is
the most straightforward one here king
the b1 was played
and the ding just played bishop captures
on h1 and it was in this position on
move 23 that magnus carlsen resigned the
game
which means that ding wins the match
three to one which is which is pretty
incredible stuff
but yeah as it didn't really matter for
the standings
magnus is uh magnus is in the playoffs
in the top four so he
he decided to obviously have some fun
and entertain everyone
while doing so so here he resigned
because uh his position is lost but
uh if he didn't resign there is actually
a a good variation where
where he could continue the game for
example bishop captures an e5
rook captures on e5 and now bishop to e2
of course you cannot allow rook to e1
check this game over so you have to
block it
and after bishop to f3 now of course
again you cannot capture because this
just wins the game so you have to play
something else and here after this
bishop to f3 move
uh there is actually rook captures an f2
which allows white to continue the game
and we basically trade down into this
captures captures and let's say captures
captures and you get this end game
which in in the long run ding would of
course win it's
uh it's only uh he's only up one pawn
but the carl since the h pawn is a
double pawn and it's a bishop against
the knight would
play on both sides of the board uh but
uh i think magnus was
was uh more disappointed with his game
to even consider
finding a line that that may result in
this position uh so
just after this uh bishop captures on h1
uh he decided to resign the game
so there we have it ding wins their
match and we are continuing to check up
on some of the other matches uh i'm not
sure when i'm gonna do so uh but
we definitely will and then we're gonna
check out the standings even though we
already know who who is going into
playoffs
uh but yeah uh that's the game i do hope
you enjoyed it uh it's
i don't think the king's game is making
a comeback but uh you know
you people might might play it here and
there uh to do you know yeah
have some fun uh but yeah i would like
to thank uh colin packard uh
thomas valeri gabriel uh uh saud
abdullah and christopher levins for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the magnus
invitational until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day